[Musique]
en direct de l'Université des maires de
l'Ouest parisien avec Valérie Pécresse
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
bonjour bonjour
vous êtes assez fidèle à cette cet
université vous venez chaque année
totalement c'est à la fois la présidente
de la région et des Yvelines qui vient
ah oui oui à double titre effectivement
alors quels sont justement des relations
du conseil régional avec les avec les
collectivités locales vous savez la
région c'est un orchestre de mer quand
la Région veut faire quelque chose si le
maire est d'accord ça se fait si le
maire n'est pas d'accord ça bloque donc
moi depuis le début j'ai
pardon lié un lien nouer un lien
chez noué un lien absolument privilégié
avec les mers j'ai une des boucles
WhatsApp avec tous les mers des Yvelines
des Hauts-de-Seine de chaque département
et je parle en direct avec eux et je
leur propose un certain nombre d'actions
quand nous décid de faire un plan de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
je l'envoie au maire pour qu'il puisse
réagir et me dire bah là j'ai besoin de
revégétaliser l'héberges de Seine là
j'ai besoin de créer un espace vert là
j'ai besoin de mettre de des panneaux
solaires donc en réalité on a un
dialogue mais vraiment très fluide très
direct sans hiérarchie parce que les
mères c'est vraiment les bras armés de
la région là on va revenir sur un
certain nombre d'actions qui ont été
dévoilés ou qui sont les vôtres
aujourd'hui la première sur le bouclier
social que vous avez lancé c'était au
mois au mois de juin c'est 200 millions
d'euros je crois pour venir pour
protéger au fond les les Franciliens
alors il y a beaucoup d'actions sur les
comptines enfin on va pas rappeler
toutes les actions mais là il va y avoir
semble-t-il des il y a déjà des hausses
des prix à cause de la crise énergétique
est-ce que il va falloir relancer encore
un nouveau bouc social d'ici quelques
quelques semaines ou quelques mois alors
dans le bouclier social il y a toute une
série de mesures mais les deux plus
emblématiques sont pour les familles
c'est le gel des tarifs des cantines
dans les villes de France parce que les
prix alimentaires ne cessent d'augmenter
vous le savez et qu'on a parfois des
enfants qui n'ont qu'un seul repas
équilibré c'est celui qui mange à la
cantine donc on a gelé les tarifs de
cantine et on a mis un tarif à 50
centimes pour les revenus les plus
modestes l'idée est évidemment de pas
faire la gratuité parce que quand on
fait la gratuité les jeunes viennent pas
déjeuner et on a du gaspillage
alimentaire donc pas de gratuité mais un
repas petit prix à 50 centimes et le
deuxième le deuxième volet c'était le
Pass imaginaire gelé le les transports
scolaires les passes juniors je l'ai
donc on a gelé c'est passe pour la
rentrée pourquoi parce que évidemment
les jeunes n'ont pas d'autres moyens de
se déplacer que les transports en commun
et donc on voulait pas leur faire payer
la hausse de l'énergie et maintenant on
est à la croisée des chemins parce que
le sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
pour les transports comment on va
réussir à payer les transports et c'est
là que intervient votre question est-ce
que il y a une nouvelle étape du
bouclier social oui la nouvelle étape
c'est zéro augmentation du Navigo nous
on a fait une proposition gouvernement
hier on a voté en conseil
d'administration d'Île-de-France
mobilité un plan en disant on peut faire
zéro augmentation du Navigo en 2023 à
condition que le gouvernement nous aide
et donc et que tout le monde se mettent
contribue donc les collectivités moi je
tiens les saluer la région mais aussi
tous les départements la ville de Paris
ont accepté d'augmenter de
7,5%. leur contribution tout le monde
augmente
c'est l'inflation ferroviaire il reste
l'état j'y viens
j'ai obtenu de la SNCF et de la RATP des
ristournes pour 2003 j'ai obtenu de
de l'État qui nous écoutent mais il
manque pour moi une hausse du versement
mobilité des entreprises en petite
couronne mais surtout à Paris les
grandes entreprises de plus de 11
salariés pourraient enfin les petites
entreprises de plus de 11 salariés
pourraient augmenter elles aussi leur
contribution de 7 et demi pour cent
c'est l'inflation ferroviaire mais pour
faire ça j'ai besoin que l'État vote un
nouveau taux de versement mobilité parce
que c'est le Parlement qui vote les taux
d'impôts c'est pas nous ce qu'on a un
problème c'est qu'il faut que les
entreprises puissent contribuer et puis
j'ai demandé à l'état de baisser la TVA
de 10% à 5,5 sur les transports ça peut
être 30 temporaire mais aujourd'hui les
transports on le voit avec la pénurie
d'essence sont des biens essentiels et
pour la transition écologique si on
coupe l'offre de train alors on
commettra une faute morale en plus d'une
faute sociale donc j'ai demandé à l'état
de baisser la TV de 10 à 5,5 sur les
transports pour nous rendre l'argent et
qu'on puisse ne pas augmenter le Navigo
75 euros un peu plus aujourd'hui tu as
7500 euros et aujourd'hui il me faut
trouver 750 millions d'euros 10
milliards les transports il faut 750
millions d'euros pour payer la SNCF pour
payer la RATP pour payer les bus donc le
sujet 750 millions d'euros et bien c'est
7 et demi pour cent d'augmentation les
collectivités ont dit oui
j'aimerais que les entreprises disent
oui
j'aimerais aussi que l'État dise il y a
un autre sujet d'ailleurs sur les
transports dans lequel vous êtes engagés
qu'ils aient la une du Parisien l'autre
jour c'est le manque de chauffeur il y a
plus de chauffeur à la RATP dans les bus
alors la situation est très contrastée
on a la grande couronne où on a une
pénurie de chauffeur de 2 % avec
quelques points noirs quelques points
noirs on en a dans les Yvelines on a
Poissy
de mémoire on doit avoir aussi
Verneuil on a deux beaux réseaux on a
deux réseaux sur les Yvelines qui ont
des problèmes vraiment
lourds en vallée de Seine et on a et ça
pardon et Saint-Germain-en-Laye Poissy
et Saint-Germain-en-Laye et on a un
certain nombre de réseaux qui vont bien
et puis on a une situation très
singulière c'est celle de la RATP la
RATP on est à 25% de services non
réalisés un quart des bus qui ne
circulent plus que dit la RATP elle dit
que elle a 17% qui sont liées à la
pénurie de chauffeur
elle a 6 % qui sont liées aux travaux
dans Paris et au bouchon et elle a 2%
qui sont liés à des mouvements sociaux
liés très directement à l'ouverture à la
concurrence qui aura lieu en 2025 donc
elle l'a RATP dans une situation tout à
fait particulière et singulière on ne
comprend pas ce qui se passe ils ont pas
très bien ils ont eu 500 arrêts maladie
frauduleux ils ont 150 conducteurs qui
sont aujourd'hui en procédure
disciplinaire de de licenciement pour
arrêt maladie frauduleux donc il y a un
climat social très tendu à la RATP
peut-être à cause de cette ouverture à
la concurrence qui doit arriver en 2025
à cause de l'insécurité parfois aussi
enfin ça peut jouer non
Paris c'est vraiment pas les endroits où
on est le plus secure du tout du tout du
tout sur le réseau donc moi ce que je
crois c'est que il y a effectivement un
début de mouvement social à la RATP
préventif parce que l'ouverture à la
concurrence elle se fait en grande
couronne mais elle se fait pas en petite
couronne alors ce qui est un peu
paradoxal c'est que la RATP est contente
candidater sur les réseaux de bus de
grande couronne elle est contente quand
elle gagne un appel d'offre de mise en
concurrence mais elle ne veut pas la
concurrence dans Paris alors pourquoi
est-ce que nous on défend la mise en
concurrence d'abord parce que c'est la
norme dans toutes les régions de France
et que ça permet d'améliorer la qualité
de service et le prix parce que quand on
est mis en concurrence Transdev Keolis
RATP ça va que la croix et ben forcément
il y a une forme d'émulation on essaie
de faire le meilleur service au meilleur
prix et donc cette concurrence elle est
saine et elle permettra aux usagers à
terme de faire des économies et d'avoir
un meilleur service je voudrais qu'on
aborde aussi la question de
l'environnement puisque vous êtes de
lancer le PRAC le plan régional
d'adaptation au changement climatique
c'est un plan de
de 2 milliards je crois
donc c'est un plan extrêmement ambitieux
avec plusieurs points là aussi
pourquoi la pourquoi c'est à la région
de s'occuper justement du changement
climatique on a l'impression que ça
devrait être une prérogative de l'État
une charge de l'État moi je crois que en
matière écologique il faut penser
globale donc il y a effectivement l'état
un rôle de régulation mais il faut agir
locale je vous ai parlé des maires ce
PRAC il va se décliner grâce aux
communes c'est quoi le PRAC c'est de
dire nous allons construire un espace
vert à moins de 10 minutes de chez vous
pour vous faire un abri climatique pour
vous pour que vous ayez des points
d'ombre on va vous mettre une
millefontaine en Île-de-France pour que
vous ayez des points d'eau on va vous
mettre des ombrières on va
re-végétaliser 5000 hectares en
Île-de-France dans les villes pour
pouvoir justement là encore faire
baisser la température de quelques
degrés on va contre les inondations donc
tout ça ça se fait commune par commune
nous avons identifié 138 communes dans
lesquelles il y a des terrains d'au
moins cinq hectares qu'on peut
re-végétaliser et on va travailler avec
elle et on va les aider à faire ça et on
va travailler aussi avec la société
civile je rappelle qu'il y a ce qu'on
appelle le budget participatif
environnemental toutes les associations
de toutes les communes peuvent demander
à faire financer leur micro projet
environnementaux leur potager urbain
leur lampadaire LED ils peuvent leur
abriver l'eau tout ça par la région
jusqu'à 10000 euros c'est 100% la région
qui paye parce que tous ces micro
projets en fait vont permettre des
changements concrets concrets et qui
sont visibles et c'est ces petits
ruisseaux qui vont faire la grande
rivière de du sauvetage de la planète et
d'ailleurs ce plan préventif pour un
certain nombre de choses sur la santé
notamment prévenir la santé des plus
fragiles etc mais c'est aussi un plan
offensif c'est à dire que vous associez
les entreprises vous permettez aux
agriculteurs aussi de de changer leur
méthode de travail enfin de s'adapter au
changement climatique donc c'est aussi
un plan d'avenir c'est pas juste
peut-être absolument et on va faire
quelque chose de très innovant avec
France carbone à gris on va
permettre que
tout le carbone qui va être économisé
grâce à la transition écologique des de
nos agriculteurs et de nos exploitations
agricoles puissent être achetés par des
entreprises qui ont besoin de compenser
leurs émissions carbone donc on va faire
payer la transition carbone des
exploitations agricoles par les
entreprises via une délégation régionale
de France carbone à gris qui va nous
aider et la région sera partenaire de
cette transition écologique pour
rapprocher les entreprises qui polluent
et les agriculteurs qui dépolluent leurs
exploitations alors on voit bien que
cette ce adaptation au changement
climatique évidemment c'est un effort
collectif il y a la région vous disiez
il y a les villes est-ce que justement
il y a les évidemment enfin il y a tous
les Français est-ce qu'on n'est pas
justement en manque aujourd'hui dans une
société qui est un peu fracturée qui est
un peu qui a parfois un peu désespéré de
grands projets collectifs comme ça je
crois que si on veut redonner aux
Français confiance dans la politique et
c'est vrai que ça part un peu dans tous
les sens je pense qu'il faut avoir une
vision faut leur dire où est-ce qu'on
veut aller nous en Île-de-France on veut
aller vers une métropole équilibrée on
verrait concilier la ville l'homme et la
nature on veut continuer à construire du
logement mais à en construire mieux et
sans grignoter sur les espaces agricoles
donc on veut mettre de l'emploi près de
chez l'habitant on veut qu'on se
transporte moins on veut qu'on avoir des
transports propres on défend une vision
d'une région qui sera 0 carbone
qui sera zéro ressources nette donc
complètement circulaire avec du
recyclage et qui sera zéro
artificialisation nette ça veut dire
qu'on va renaturer la ville pour pouvoir
construire en grande couronne donc vous
voyez on a une vision alors cette vision
elle est parfois contraignante parfois
ça m'oblige à faire des choix parfois
c'est plus à dire non à certaines choses
mais quand on sait où on va je pense
qu'on peut entraîner les Français avec
soi et quand vous avez fait de la
présidentielle vous avez beaucoup parlé
du fer qui voilà l'action quoi c'est
vrai que les mères qui sont là ils
voient réellement le résultat de leurs
actions est-ce que quand on est
président de conseil régional on voit on
a aussi cette visibilité ou c'est plus
long ecoutez il se trouve que
aujourd'hui on est à Port-Marly et donc
je suis allée avec le maire de
Port-Marly visiter les nouvelles berges
de Port-Marly ces berges c'était c'était
une décharge assez ouvert et bien grâce
à la région on les a complètement
revégétalisés on les a Ré partager on
les a consolidés pour éviter les
inondations et bien ça c'est du concret
et je peux vous dire que tous les
habitants de Port-Marly le voient et le
voient au quotidien ce qu'il faut
peut-être c'est le faire plus savoir
faire savoir ce que fait la région les
lycées neufs les transports neufs la
réhabilitation des villes la rénovation
urbaine tout ce que la Région finance à
mon avis doit être davantage mis en
valeur j'avoue que pendant la campagne
présidentielle je me suis promené
évidemment j'ai visité toute la France
tous les chemins de France et j'ai été
en Occitanie j'ai été en Rhône-Alpes je
me suis aperçu qu'il y avait des
présidents de région qui savaient mieux
faire savoir
un équipement était financé par la
Région donc je vais m'en inspirer et
quand vous vous promenez comme ça dans
cette région ou en France comme vous
l'avez fait vous êtes plutôt optimiste
sur le sur l'avenir de ce pays moi je
vais vous dire on est un pays
extraordinaire mais il faut de temps en
temps qu'on voit le vert à moitié plein
et pas à moitié vide et de temps en
temps qu'on soit fier de nous je vous
donne un exemple l'accessibilité dans
les transports moi je me suis un peu
fâché ce matin avec le ministre des
Transports parce que on a on est en
train de faire un plan d'accessibilité
en tout type de handicap dans les
transports de 2 milliards 4 c'est
historique on n'a jamais fait un effort
comme ça SNCF RATP les bus tout les
enfin même les endives vélos et on fait
ce plan de milliard 4 on va être à 85 %
accessible pour en 2024 pour les JO et
j'entends dire c'est pas assez mais
voyez Londres a organisé les JO Tokyo à
organiser les JO et ben ils étaient
moins accessibles que doux et qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dit quand ils organisé les JO
ils ont dit regardez comme nous avons
fait un effort comme nous sommes bons
sur l'accessibilité comme ces
magnifiques oui parce que c'est les
Japonais et c'est des Anglais et eux ils
sont fiers de même ils sont fiers de
leur réalisation ils sont fiers du
travail qu'ils accomplissent ils sont
pas tout le temps en train de voir le
vert à moitié vide et de dire on n'a pas
tout fait bien voilà et ça c'est le
problème c'est le problème de la France
soyons un peu plus fier de nous faisons
un tout petit peu moins d'auto vraiment
franchement on a des entreprises
formidables on a des Français qui sont
formidables on fait des choses
formidables soyons-en un peu plus fiers
en tout cas vous avez la diacre
à la politique merci beaucoup Valérie
Pécresse merci
[Musique]